welcome to interactive visualization
with bouquet my name is Brian vandeven
I'm really happy to be here I'm with
continuum analytics just a quick word
we're one of the sponsors of pi data
we're very happy to be a potato sponsor
bringing Python tools and deployment
ease to a data analytics and data
science all over the place so we operate
in a lot of domains we also generate a
lot of different technologies things
like number blaze of talks on blaze
yesterday as well as Conda and anaconda
and of course Spokane this talk today is
about about bouquet so what is bouquet
so voce is a library in Python really
actually will see that it's two
libraries in Python and JavaScript for
interactive visualizations inside the
browser and there's a lot of things
we're trying to do with bouquet it's
it's got a fairly wide scope we'll talk
about a lot of the capabilities of
bouquet today but some of the things
they can do are to generate very novel
graphics so one of the questions we're
sort of trying to answer is you know
people ask where is ggplot for Python
right and so we're trying to create
something along the lines of ggplot for
python that can generate very
interesting you know grammar of graphics
style visualizations from python that
are in the browser we also want to build
to handle streaming and large data right
so if we have maybe dashboard that has
stock ticker data or real-time data
coming from some sensor wanna be able to
have plots that can be updated
continuously from that data we also want
able to handle large data that's through
interactive down sampling or some other
techniques that we'll talk about in a
minute that's definitely an important
use case for us again browser is a
first-class concern we want to be able
to target the browser certainly 2014 I
mean that the certainly very important
to have a you know ability to sort of
generate web apps and generate data
applications in the browser across
platforms so that's a first-class
concern for us is being able to generate
these plots in the browser matplotlib
compatibility we have some level of that
at the moment as well certainly very
important a lot of us have matplotlib
code I certainly have a lot of matlab
code laying around so won't be able to
leverage all of the years man use of
work that have gone into that pot lib
and to be able to you know provide an
easy path to use and generate bouquet
sharts from bama matlab code last but
not least no need to write JavaScript
right so I don't like to write
JavaScript I'll have to write a lot of
it for bouquet but I don't want you know
you don't have to write JavaScript and
so that's really
a goal behind bilk is to keep keep
things very simple keep them in Python
and we'll see that so there's definitely
some interest in this sort of thing you
know we just passed about two thousand
stars on github I thought was pretty
crazy a lot of forks hovering around
10,000 downloads a month which i think
is also pretty pretty intense I've never
really been part of a growing open
source project that sort of started with
no users and now has quite a few years
it's been a really learning journey for
me and so that's really awesome so
anyway there's definitely AI people
interested in this and so we have a
pretty active mailing list we have a lot
of questions on stack overflow now it's
actually getting difficult to keep up
with we'd love to get more people
involved and helping out and talk about
that later as well Sony all the features
that I talked about maybe let's examine
those a little bit more details so
interactive means obviously what you
might think of with interactive Claude
spanning dragging and zooming of
selections and the important thing about
the selections is that with the bouquet
server which is this optional server you
can use with bouquet you can round trip
things like selections to and from a
running Python process so you can
imagine having us user make a selection
with a lasso tool or box selection tool
on your plot that gets back to your
Python process that can inform some
further computation right you maybe you
want to do a regression through the
selected points or some other kind of
statistical statistical measure through
those points and then you can update the
plot based on that so you can have this
full sort of two-way communication
possible things like resizing the plot
and entirely on the client size so in
the browser you can drag resize these
plots hover and click tools that allow
you to sort of add additional drill down
in type information look into additional
columns of data that aren't presented
visually but you can present in the
hover tool as you hover over different
glyphs on the plot that sort of thing
and then widget so people also ask about
you know what's what's pythons answer to
our shiny and so we're trying to be that
as well so you can go to bouquet top I
dated up org there's documentation site
there we have a gallery right now it's
full of static pops let me go ahead and
bring that up Safari they changed their
icon so if we go here to book it up high
data or we can go to the gallery there's
all kinds of plots here that we can take
a look at and we can drill down and see
these and see the source code we're
going to be in the process of expanding
this gallery to include some server
examples these are all right now static
plots by which I mean they have static
data embedded in the document they still
lots of interactive tools so anyway
we're going to be expanding our gallery
pretty soon it's a quick preview of that
okay great anyway I talked about
interactivity in widgets here's another
example again we want to be able to have
our shiny like dashboards in Python so
you can have the you know sliders and
drop downs all kinds of widgets that
inform further computations or update
the state of the plot we can see a
couple of examples of that as well here
too many windows open find the one that
I won't show here we go so here's an
example of a nice data table widget we
have lots of drop-down so again we can
sort of drill down inside of our data
and running to the selection here and we
can see the selections linked inside the
chart you know we can do all kinds of
multiple selections as well we have a
nice hover tool that hovers over the
data here so that's sort of one example
another one here cross filter kind of
example dashboarding we'll come back to
this later but this allows you to sort
of drill down into your data as well and
maybe want to select by miles per gallon
have the chart update maybe you want to
do some faceting this is pretty early
tool we're going to be working on
fleshing this one out quite a bit
another example with widgets here again
tour a little stock correlation tool we
can do a selection here on the chart and
see that there are linked links
elections there on the bottom as well as
selections here that are links so if we
do on the selection on the chart here
you know we can see how the other charts
update so it's very easy to have this
kind of linked brushing linked panning
and linked behavior in Python that's
typically expressed by sharing something
so we'll talk about the object model for
cocaine a little bit later but typically
in boquete if you want to have linked
panning for instance you share a range
between two plots or if you want to have
linked selections you'll share a data
source between those two plots and so
it's very easy to spell and sort of
explain these concepts and how to link
link charts in Boca examples here ah
here's that little function creator so
again just sort of our shiny light
capability the ability to have these
nice feedback between Python and we're
working to have more of this available
in pure standalone documents that you
can simply transport right now a lot of
this will have to use the bouquet server
again the focus or was always optional
but it does for you know afford extra
features like these dashboards and
widgets and whatnot go back to do a redo
so there was that linked tables example
as well I also mentioned things like
novel graphics so that's again we want
to be able to let people have the
capability to write very interesting
visualizations right so just a couple of
examples of here the first one up on the
upper left is actually a seaborne chart
so I mentioned that map plot live
compatibility that actually also gets us
things like ggplot2 up high and Seaborn
compatibility as well right out of the
box so that's actually a seaborne shot
seabourn plot and there's simply one
line of extra code at the bottom this is
you know dot tube okay and now all the
sudden you have a book a chart with all
of the interactive tools panning and
zooming that you have on a book a chart
but from your Seaborn code interactive
sort of interesting visualizations you
have the two here in the middle which
are actual so scatter plots of
rectangles but you can generate sort of
the periodic table from that or this
calendar that has these nice drill down
hover tools available over those as well
there's the lame is current start that's
a reproduction of a Mike Bostock chart
you know he did co-occurrences of all
the characters and lame is and you can
do a scatter and see what you know how
many occurrences there were little
vector field quiver plot there at the
bottom you can do some kinds of mapping
things is now we're still working on
adding additional GIS and sort of
projections and mapping capabilities but
right now you can still do fairly
sophisticated maps already and then
finally that upper right this kind of
interesting plot I just wanted to
reproduce this to show off capability I
saw that someone had done this in d3 and
I said I want to make sure I can do it
okay this is actually a chart from a guy
named Burton takes about 50 years old
showing the efficacy of different
antibiotics you know against different
different kinds of infections and so you
know it's interesting what happened in
this chart I've never seen this before
has a inverted radial access obviously
the better an antibiotic is the smaller
the minimum inhibitory dose will be and
so he wanted to highlight the highlight
the you know the antibiotics have had
that smaller dose and so there's
actually inverted relax I'm not sure I
would have done that in a real chart but
I thought it was kind of interesting and
certainly something that we can
reproduce here in boquete so let me
close a few tabs show off a few more
examples yeah here's that Burton chart
right so you can see that here and again
all of those things are available we can
resize the plot here all this stuff of
course works in the notebook as well
right so all this is available in the
ipython
do here's that calendar charts if I go
to the gallery here's that again lame is
chart we can sort of see the nice hover
tool operates on that we can go back to
our periodic table see a better example
maybe of the hover so here there's a lot
of data and we have a column data source
that has a lot of different data not all
of its visually displayed but we can
have this hover tool that can drill down
into those additional columns of data
and display them as we hover over the
different cliffs sort of again nice for
sort of exploration and drill down as
well streaming and dynamic data
certainly something else that we want to
be able to handle what I mentioned the
case of maybe you have stock ticker data
maybe you have sensor data whatever we
want to handle that and so typically
that's handled with the bouquet server
again the Wade bouquet it's architected
we'll talk about that towards the end is
that if you push data to the server the
plot automatically reacts an update so
it's a very easy to have streaming data
you can just push data onto the bouquet
server and that will work so we can see
a few examples of that as well I go over
here 22 spectrogram demo so this is
actually sort of a hybrid example this
one doesn't use the focus or with the
heavy lifting of creating all the plots
is just a little bit of Python code that
creates these plots and then there's a
small bit of JavaScript that actually
does an AJAX call to a REST API to get
the audio data the FFT that's being done
in Python and then it presents that and
we have this nice updating plot and we
have this silly little radial graphic
equalizer there at the bottom as well
just to sort of show that working so we
can sort of see an example of let's see
that I get a little tone generator here
yeah so yeah you know we can see sure
enough there's our nice spike going up
and down so I was embarrassed to another
PI data by Peter Wang who asked me to
whistle and I can't actually whistle
this is embarrassing good so now I bring
my faithful a tone generator to show
that off but anyway so that's a nice
example again if streaming data we want
to make that a first-class concern as
well so there's a lot of different ways
you can use the bouquet server but you
can also get a handle to your plot in
JavaScript and if you have JavaScript
code that's already making you know Ajax
calls to rest api's or getting data
through JavaScript it's possible to
update using javascript as well so we
want to make it very flexible to have
lots of different ways to embed another
example here let's see I have it open
I may not actually let's see
so here's an example that uses the
bouquet server so this is another you
know at the bottom we have a little bit
of code that generates the plot really
there's this line annular wedge right
here that generates the plot for drawing
annular wedges and then we have this
simple wild true loop that simply stores
new data coordinates for the different
parts of the glyph and you can see it
says you know current sessions store the
objects and sure enough we see the plot
reacting to that and updating a real
time and all the standard tools you know
resizing panning all those are available
resize tool okay I don't know why it's
not letting me select resize tool that's
interesting but anyway all the standard
tools they're available we can reset
that as well so I'm actually running off
master so I'm gonna have a few little
bugs there that's fun live demos even
made even more fun by running off
running off master okay I also mentioned
things like linked panning and linked
brushing for interactivity so here's
some examples of that you know here I
have shared a range between some plots
so in the first two examples here I've
shared both the x and y range so when I
pan the first plot the second one
updates its X&Y range but the third plot
only shares that X range so you can see
it only you know has links painting in
the X direction so it's very easy to
express that you can see here I've just
passed the range from the first flight
into the second one and so very easy to
spell again zooming does all that as
well link to brushing another thing
again if you have selections here I've
got a plot that I want to make
selections on so i can pick my box
selection tool and i can select some
point so that's a box zoom tool sorry
box select and i can see that the
corresponding points and the data source
are updated on the other plot right so i
can use all kinds of selection tools
maybe I've got my lasso tool over here
and i can see that work so again very
easy to spell that in this case instead
of sharing arrange we simply share this
data source so you can see they have the
same data source object passed into them
so it's very easy to spell this kind of
linking and sharing with booking those a
few more tabs make it easier to navigate
it later okay
what else can we show off big data
another concern of ours we want to go to
handle large data sets so there's a
couple of different ways this might be
expressed you might have like large data
cubes and obviously you don't want to
chip gigabytes of data into the browser
maybe you just have a lot of points if
you're doing like a scatter plot and you
have you know 10 million 100 million
points and you try to plot that
obviously you'll just get sort of a
solid mass of color and you can try to
solve that using things like alpha you
know compositing but we actually have a
couple of different features we have
some down sampling we also have a
something called abstract rendering
which is a contributor our contribution
from our academic collaborator so voce
is actually I've actually mentioned is
supported in part by the ex-date
initiative of DARPA and so we have an
academic collaborator Joseph Cottam who
has been involved with the stencil
grammar and proto biz and he's got some
really fantastic ideas about how to
handle her large when you have this
large hundred million data points what
can you do with it to sort of
intelligently extract information from
it in a visual way and that's called
abstract rendering and so we're working
on porting some of that into bouquet but
the basic idea is that you can do sort
of a pre rasterization you know you
imagine when you're actually drawing all
of these graphical primitives to the
screen you're actually filling in a
memory buffer an array of you know point
and they get drawn to the screen but you
don't actually have to draw to the
screen you can separate that process and
you can keep statistical information
about where these glyphs would be drawn
on a synthetic canvas if you will and
then with this statistical information
you can do a much more intelligent down
sampling or you can do much more
intelligent sort of alpha compositing
you can have it for instance a non
constant alpha over your data I like to
think of it a sort of high dynamic range
HDR for data if you're familiar with HDR
photography we can see a couple of
examples here of big data sort of it as
well not super big data but some bigger
day that you can normally get in the
browser so this is actually I think a
four gig data cube is living on a
digital ocean box somewhere it's an
ocean surface temperature data and looks
a little bit different so we got an
older version of ok that's been running
this for a while but you can see as i
zoom in i get to this nice progressive
refinement right that's fairly again
that's it this data is not on my laptop
it's intended you know a box somewhere
across the u.s. and so I can get in I
can zoom in i can get this nice
progressive refinement even over
conference Wi-Fi i think works works
pretty well so this this is afforded by
that bouquet server so i mentioned the
book a server you know is an optional
piece of bouquet also bsd license like
the rest of boat
okay and it's a place where interesting
things can happen right so we can do
things like server side down sampling of
this for data cube and have returned
just enough data to render in the
browser another example is with this
time series down sampling I think this
is a 2.1 million points and so again I
can zoom in and get progressive
refinement on the data and I can have
this nice interactivity even though
again I on the server there's you know
about two million points finally the
abstract rendering I don't have a demo
to show up but I can point you at the
docs for that there are some early
examples of this sort of an early
feature but again the idea is you can do
very intelligent down Semak so this I
think was about a hundred thousand
points and it sort of been alpha
compositing a much more intelligent way
to let you see greater areas of detail
sort of high and low than you would be
other otherwise be able to okay and as I
mentioned all this works in the in the
notebook right so you can use little
it's really flexible how you can use
boca you can create standalone HTML
documents with the data embedded that
still have lots of interactive tools you
can use the server that gets you even
more kind of interactivity and widgets
and the ability to have this back and
forth between a running process you can
do this in the notebook or outside the
notebook you can embed them in flash
gapps or Django apps there's all kinds
of ways to embed bouquet plots and that
I mentioned no JavaScript right so
that's the really important part so
here's some examples sort of a typical
prototypical kind of code you would use
to generate this right in this first
case with Texas what we want to do is to
actually show all these counties so
those are really polygons so we have
this patches glyph that we can just sort
of vectorize over our data and it shows
all the different patches just sort of
fall out of that with the appropriate
colors again a histogram here here we
can see we can draw a bunch of quads and
some lines for the cumulative
distribution and as well and this has
actually been simpler so we have a very
layered approach for api's in in boquete
this is sort of the middle layer api
there's a very low level object api
talked about in a second there's this
middle sort of MATLAB matplotlib level
of API and then there's a charts API
that we're working on this even higher
level that's really where you get sort
of one liners for things like histograms
things like time series you can make
them you know even even simpler than
this right sort of you pass your data in
it generates these schematic statistical
kind of charts and so that's that work
is ongoing but it's a is it some charts
there already
another example here's just some
elements data this is colored by I think
colored by their melting points actually
a contributor made this chart and
donated it to our gallery love to get
more bouquet charts that people create
be able to add them to our gallery I'll
be really cool but anyway this is uh
again fairly straightforward to create
from Python no JavaScript so that's the
the main thing maybe just a quick few
words about the architecture and then
we'll take some questions so this is
sort of what plotting to the browser
typically looks like or has looked like
in the past right you would imagine
generating a bunch of code you actually
generate JavaScript programs right to
draw the charts and that's what you ship
off to the browser and it's sort of a
one-off you know you know one shot kind
of approach right so you have some model
and it generates this code and your
server serves it up and it draws the
chart that you want that's great it's
done there's a lot of examples of that
sort of thing happening again you don't
have things like data streaming or this
nice model okay jess has a little bit of
a different model right we tried to make
it very decoupled between the browser
and and whatever its generating the
actual models for the plot so I like to
think of it sort of as a dynamic scene
graph rendering compiler and so the
reason I say that is because there's
actually an object graph that's created
in Python and then optic craft is
serialized and sent over to Jason and
it's then it's reconstituted in the
browser as a backbone a set of backbone
models and then and then beaucage is the
client library uses that model to render
the scene so just in case you're curious
about the kind of tools we use right now
we use html5 canvas there's some talk
about maybe looking into WebGL canvas to
get even better performance we use
backbone for our NBC we actually most of
okay jess is written in CoffeeScript
interesting sort of language that
compiles to JavaScript uses AMD modules
and it's works perfectly well for
instance in jsfiddle so you can go to
take fiddle and play around with it and
and again we grew all this JavaScript so
you don't have to write JavaScript so
this is sort of a notional diagram of
what you know the model for bouquet is
is we create this object graph the
server you know it's a serialized
version of that that gets shipped to the
client and then that same object craft
is reproduced inside the browser and
that's a very flexible thing but the
book I server adds even more capability
right because now we can connect the
object graph that's stored in the server
directly to the client to the browser we
can use for instance of
socket connection to have those updates
so again if you update the object graph
in the server the plot responds
automatically and immediately and
updates itself as well so if you push a
new data to the plot you'll get new data
in the plot or pushing your renders new
glyphs all of those will show up as well
excuse me it definitely had a nice time
at the happy hour last night talking
loudly in bars is I left my voice with a
bit more of a stern authority than it
normally has i guess but hopefully
that's not too bad so just a quick look
at what this translation actually looks
like so here you might see some code
that generates this iris you know plot
so this is the iris dataset with the
different kinds of species of irises and
colored by their species and sort of
what's there you know in this case I
guess it's the petal length versus the
petal width and so we could we can see
what that plot looks like actually on
our our gallery oh the gallery here you
know it's just this iris data and again
so it's a fairly straightforward zoom in
and out and pan all around so that's
good so yeah so that's what the Python
looks like what does that actually get
turned into just you know in case you're
sort of curious it gets turn into this
right so this is a lot of stuff you
don't have to worry about that's the
reason I show it to use this is what
we're trying to save people from having
sort of deal with this or writing this
sort of code but if you do look at it if
you stare around you can sort of see
that the structure of it right there's a
little bit of code that sort of sets up
you know all the models but all the all
of the data that optic graph dimension
is stored in that all models equals JSON
data that's that big pile of data on the
last slide you can see there's you know
there's these Jason objects that say
that there are things like you know axes
and grids and plots and there's a you
know circle renderers and column data
sources and so the data is actually all
embedded now in this in this particular
example but you could also have
references to data sources live on the
server which is how that's streaming and
streaming and updating plots work anyway
so this is this is sort of the forty
thousand foot view with all of that
detail pulled out but we can zoom in a
little bit more we can see this is for
instance it's prototypical kind of
serialization of one of those objects
you know here's a column data source it
has these columns X and you know it's
referenced by this data range that sort
of thing and the reason I mention all of
this is because you know pythons not the
only language that can generate Jason
and this I think is actually really
exciting as well so there's
one of our contributors a big Scala guy
so he's actually started Scott Labine
dings for bouquet there is Julia guys
well Samuel calm Calvin has been working
on Julia bindings for bouquet so native
native library and Julia that can speak
to boca Jas and there's some folks on
Twitter who are thinkers starting to
collaborate on an R I would love to see
an r binding for bouquets well but you
could imagine anything I mean you could
we could write MATLAB my name's for
bouquet or anything like that so I'd
love to see bindings for bouquet
everywhere obviously a continuum were
heavily a Python shop and so that's
where we spent most of our time and
efforts are investing in python bindings
but there's no reason it couldn't be
pretty much anything anyway what's next
on the road map first ox he mentioned we
should have a release right after
Thanksgiving 0.7 release a lot of new
features there some of the stuff I've
been showing it's been using that new
code that will be into that release a
lot of new tools much better tools touch
support we also finally have that much
better data table that i just showed off
their is in the new release but in the
future we're going to be doing lots of
sort of data-driven layout so you could
imagine wanting to position elements on
the plot or the plots themselves you
know sort of faceting style layout
driven by data and so that's that's
coming being able to edit plot
attributes directly on the plot so you
can edit the title or manipulate the
properties of the tools right there on
the plot some of that's already there as
well you can you can turn on some of the
inside two inspectors and turn them off
in the plot SVG output this some people
ask for I'm not sure what the time frame
but this is it something that's
important we want to get to i'm sort of
pinning my hopes on matplotlib enhanced
enhancement proposal 25 they're working
towards a serialization scheme from a
poly but that would be really fantastic
it allow Jacob and applause as npl d3
and plot lee and bouquet to all leverage
all the work that's gone into mount pot
live for instance to generate static SVG
and PDF and eps outputs and also give us
better compatibility going the other way
so hopefully that will will go forward i
don't know what the time frame for that
is we want to make a nice command-line
tool you can imagine something like the
new plot riding the command line but you
could also imagine tailing a continuous
log file to a bouquet command-line tool
and simply having an updating plot in
the browser automatically so that would
be kind of cool and again improved GIS
stuff is big high priority for us as
well some other just last few examples
here again some data apps the cross
filter tool i think i showed this is a
product we might actually build on top
of bouquet and blaze
you know that's our ultimate goal is to
sort of build interesting things on top
of these but shove some of these other
things first calendar okay i'm not sure
where i lost that tab but it still show
a few other things one of the mention
there are a lot of example notebooks up
on NB viewer so we have a nice NB viewer
sites on the main NB viewer page you can
go there you can find a ton of notebooks
as well as the tutorial example so the
tutorial notebooks have been modified
taken from their original dot py file
format modified by christine dog and
these fantastic notebooks that have like
hidden solutions directly in line the
notebook and so i encourage you guys to
check those out but there's also just
example notebooks and you know it's a
really fantastic resource to encourage
you guys to look at that too is a sort
of example of that data portal ID idea
behind this data portal again this might
be an actual product that we make is
that we want to have a catalog of our
data that we can interact with blaze and
so we can interact with a lot of
different kinds of data because we're
using blaze we can farm out compute to a
lot of different computer fun tens
because we're using plays but then we
wanna be able to publish and create
dashboards bouquet plots and charts from
that so this is a the idea is very easy
being able to create these plots but
also to publish them as dashboards and
lay them out in the way that we want so
that's some of the things that are you
know coming along last but not least so
how to contribute again everything here
is BSD license you know bouquet the the
JavaScript library the Python the server
is all BSD license we definitely would
love everyone to use it and give us
feedback that's the primary way that we
get you know bug reports and feature
requests and move things forward
definitely feel free to though engages
if you have customer requirements we're
always happy to sort of work on all
kinds of things with people not just for
integrating our code but if you know we
can bring hopefully analytical and
visually visualization expertise as well
if you have any need for that but all of
that you know work that people come and
engage us with certainly helps our open
source efforts and move the open source
tools forward so it's up there on on
bouquet if you go to the book I
organization on github you'll see a lot
of different projects now it's actually
pretty exciting to see the standard
bouquet library but you can also see
again bouquets Scala bouquet notebooks
for the env viewer notebooks hopefully
bouquet are will make an appearance
there as well so anyway I think I'm just
about out of time but try to take a few
questions any any questions yeah
yeah that's that now that's a very early
early projects and it's also that's
probably going to be a commercial
product built on top of booking unless P
up you have a question
okay so what do mean by guess so the
questions about hot ah yeah yeah so
hover is implemented for almost all the
booths we don't have it yet for hit
testing for line so that's one reason
you might not have fun are lines but it
works for just about every other cliff
circles and scatter type lifts and
patches you can definitely get both the
screen coordinates the data space
coordinates as well as the index into
the into the column data source of which
glyph you're actually hovering over so
if you want to come find me later we can
we can talk about specifics but yeah all
of that information is available other
questions yeah
yeah that's that's an ongoing process
making that better this is an area where
feedback from users is really really
very valuable so I would say it used to
be fairly difficult and now it's a
little bit better and we want to keep
smoothing those rough edges over
basically there are some layout classes
see if I can find maybe an example here
in github and show for instance that
spectrogram example so again the
spectrogram example is sort of a nice
example sort of hybrid development where
most of the heavy lifting was done in
Python we had a little bit of JavaScript
that actually updated the data because
we can grab that plot from javascript in
so that's kind of good people ask for
that that's pretty cool but if I find do
embed spectrogram there we go I look at
spectrogram dom py here at the bottom
you can see i create this layout most of
the code in yours actually the fft in
the pi audio sampling but here you can
see i create those for plot try to
create an image rgba for that waterfall
plot i create two line plots for the
power spectrum and for the and for the
actual signal and then i create this
annular wedge chart for that sort of
integrated you know bend radial graphic
equalizer plot so there's these four
plots you know here and here and here
and here and I put them in a V box and I
put the you know the view box in another
v box and I I passed that layout is what
I actually return and that's what I call
show on and so it's it's getting better
right we'd love to make it even even
more better but that really again
feedback from users is invaluable for
that especially new users the they have
the best perspective on you know why is
this harder than it should be or why
can't I find the information and so that
new user sort of perspective is
incredibly valuable to me unfortunately
goes away the longer you use the tool so
if you guys do try out bouquet please
give us feedback and let us know what we
can make better and what else we can
improve but other questions like we have
room for maybe one more question yeah oh
oh thank you
oh yeah great question so right now
there is some you can do some kinds of
integration with the ipython widgets I
mean you can use it to update things in
notebook so you can use it updated plot
there's not a very tight integration yet
we want to make that a much tighter
integration so we do have our own widget
toolkit I mean and the reason for that
is because we need to work outs i mean
the widget in the ipython notebook
basically assume we're running ipython
kernel and we need to be able to work in
dashboards and places where there is a
night python colonel right and
standalone documents even so that's why
we have to have our own sort toolkit but
we do want to work very well with the
ipython widgets as well and so that's
also on our road map is sort of it make
that integration even tighter than it is
it's certainly doable we just haven't we
have a infinite to-do list you know of
course so again please come help ok
great ok all right i think i think
that's time so thank you guys for coming
talk